you
hello and welcome to the 14th machine
learning and pattern recognition for use
with stock and Forex algorithmic and
automated trading where we left off I
was making some of you guys cry probably
with all variables and issues that have
already been arisen but in this video
we're going to continue a dredging on
you now and what I'd like to do in this
video is since we're plotting all of the
patterns on the exact same plot what
would be cool is if we plotted those
patterns a outcome right so every
pattern that we and we've done this
already so you have to worry too much
not too much heavy coding now every
pattern that we put into storage
we also stored the outcome of that
pattern so what would be cool is if we
plotted the outcome of that pattern
right and then you can see visually kind
of what is the prediction like where
will this line go so that's what we're
going to do in this video is we're gonna
actually plot it out visually to see you
know where the line is predicted to go
and then obviously eventually back test
so what we need to do is come down here
and in the graph part you see we have if
let's see if have found equals one then
we're going to start graphing and then
we're running through this for loop so
now the next thing that we want to do is
each pattern in plot pad array right
that matches what do we want to do well
we're going to obviously we're plotting
that up but what else should we do well
let's get the outcome right so if you
remember first what we need to do is do
few let's just call this future points
so like the points in the future of
these patterns we want to do pattern
array index and we want to index each
hat so what we're doing is we're you
know calling for the index number of the
Pat in the pattern array because that
should match the exact index number of
the outcome of that pattern in the
outcome array so now what we needed to
earn the performance array so now what
we want to do is not only are we
plotting
the patterns we want to plot the
outcomes so what we're going to do now
is underneath guess right here sorry for
the O's I'm like trying to talk and then
think ahead of what we want to do so I
guess what was put here so we'll just do
plot scatter and in theory keep in mind
this would really be plot probably 55
because it's 20 to 30 in the future it
ends on 30 so in theory it would be 25
so oh I mean 25 in the futures at 55 but
we're going to make the X 35 just so
it's not like way off the chart and
distorts things but just understand that
this isn't a perfect representation of
the actual chart but it will give us the
idea of the prediction so anyway we'll
just say 35 and then we're going to say
the Y is going to be that performance
array performance array and we're
head-on with my first performance array
and then we want to say remember the
future points is the index number so
then we just say future points so that
will yield the performance subsequently
you know be cool is if we colored these
dots right and actually said you know
color coded it so green if that
prediction was a good one in red if it
wasn't so let's go up here and come back
do this and we'll say uh if um I think
we can just perform its array future
points is greater then Pat for rec 29 so
that last index number which is : if
that is the case then we'll say peak
color equals and we'll make it this
green it's a 24 BC 0 0 is kind of a
greenish and then else so if that is not
the case so if it's not greater so if it
is greater then we're squirt we're
predicting a rise if it is not greater
then we're predicting a fall you
if you wanted to be perfect you would
have you know if it's equal but the
chances of it being equal are so tiny
that I'm not going to worry about that
so we'll make this D 40,000 and that'll
be kind of a reddish color so then we
come back down here to this plot that we
were making the scatter plot and we'll
say C for color equals P color and then
we're going to give it an alpha of 0.4
the reason we want to do this is just in
case actually let's just do it 0.3 or I
can't even make up my mind only 0.3 for
now and see how that looks
the reason we want to do that is just in
case a couple plots are overlapping each
other or right on each other or at least
close to each other we'll be able to
tell that visually so if they didn't
have an alpha it would be solid and so
if two plots were almost right over each
other you would miss it you wouldn't
realize that was the case so for our
visual help and since we're making this
for a visual representation it would
just help now I think that's everything
we need let's run it see if we made any
errors bring this over this is from our
last tutorial so you can ignore that so
I'll just bring this up here there's our
data and we didn't find anything so
let's continue on and while we continue
on let me see what we're acquiring let's
change this to a 70 I think the next one
is a pattern
but we'll change it at 70 just in case
so if this doesn't yield a pattern I'll
run it again there we go we didn't get a
pattern cool okay so this is what you
should have gotten so here is the
pattern in question and then here are
the dots and keep in mind this is
obviously distorted a little bit so if
we were to just look at the pattern
itself don't shoot
let me try this again that right now you
kind of understand that okay here we are
back in the directional so when you get
home it looks like okay so this is a
flat lawn pattern cool anyway so we can
see the predictions now and as you can
see some of these dots did indeed
overlap each other right like and you
can tell that they've overlapped same
thing down here these are overlapped and
then so it almost gives you the idea of
the intensity right
so cool so there's one obviously if you
were to do the math unless there's a
whole bunch of red dots right here if
you did the math it's most likely this
is a positive prediction so so anyways
now we've plotted out visually at least
the prediction but what would be nice is
to plot out reality so where did this
actually go and then we could also plot
out the average prediction as well so
where is the you know average point
abouts to be and where did we actually
where did it actually happen and then we
can see if we want to actually continue
on with this strategy so that's going to
include video number fourteen and this
time we just displayed our predictions
pretty cool it's looking good we've got
clearly a positive prediction hopefully
the outcome is positive and that's what
we're gonna be working on the next few
videos and as well as the true app true
outcome versus the true prediction and
then eventually we'll be actually back
testing this stuff to see if it's worth
our time and energy to continue because
there are actually some some more things
that I haven't even brought up in the
last video and I'd said I'd leave that I
didn't want to heat you guys with too
much too much stuff so anyways that's it
for this video as always thanks for
watching thanks for your support your
subscriptions and until next time